Hi!
I'm Jade.
I'm Nikki.
Hi.
I have never ever been in a ball pit before.
What?
You've never been in a ball pit?
No.
Okay, this is a good one.
Share three things on your bucket list.
The first one is to go skydiving.
Actually, I play the drums.
You play any instruments?
I quit everything I ever tried.
All right.
Actually fun fact, these aren't real teeth.
I have a flipper tooth.
Really?
Oh my god!
No, no, no, I can't.
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
My front tooth!
Oh my gosh!
You don't even understand.
I swear to God I feel like someone planted us here for this reason.
Destiny.
Describe the first time you fell in love.
I think it was kindergarten.
I don't remember his name, but he was beautiful.
I was in the Navy.
You were in the Navy?
And my husband was in the Navy.
Long story short, before he ever kissed me or we were ever really together,...
...he told me he loved me.
24 years later, we're more in love...
...and we're better friends than even from the very beginning.
That's true love in its finest.